[Musique]
le jeune français est très présent sur
le territoire national et représente
plus de 30 % de sa population humaine
il se différencie du reste de son espèce
par son incapacité à trouver du travail
intrinsèquement liée à son inaptitude à
sortir de son canapé son habitat naturel
salle à celle mcfly pardon merci de
poser sa voix sur notre documentaire ça
fait très plaisir
en fait j'ai improvisé juste un petit
texte d'introduction sur le documentaire
voilà au bouquet d'accord rassure moi ça
veut dire sur mon mail
ouais bien sûr avec toutes les
thématiques ira dans le docu ouais bah
justement j'ai pris des notes pour les
crèmes à bois en fait nous on essaye
d'apporter un regard nouveau sur la
jeunesse de casser un peu les clichés
qu'on a l'habitude d'entendre
je te propose on s'en tient à notre
texte ok le tient je le garde est résumé
par dont on a tous entre 20 et 30 ans et
on a déjà été confronté aux mêmes
stéréotypes sur la jeunesse chômage
délinquance fainéantise on croirait
presque tout était mieux avant
[Musique]
seulement voilà aujourd'hui en france
des milliers de gens de notre âge
s'activent
chacun à leur échelle pour construire la
société de demain
[Musique]
qu'il s'agisse de l'environnement de la
politique ou de la culture ces jeunes
s'engagent pour faire bouger les choses
et le bas on n'en parle jamais
aujourd'hui notre but n'est pas de faire
comme s'il n'y avait aucun problème et
c'est mon truc des solutions existent
déjà et on vous emmène à leur rencontre
donc rendez vous le 2 mai à 20h 55 sur
france 4 on voulait faire un état de la
jeunesse différent de ce qu'on a
l'habitude de voir on espère que ça vous
plaira et rassurez vous il ya aussi des
blagues dans le documentaire
[Musique]